βάλλουμε ξανά το κομμάτι τις ηλεγχόμενης καύσεις στο παιδί ελεγχόμενη πόσκηση ξεκίνουμε φέδος τι σημαίναι
αυτός εβλέπου που συνοφριας διερωτάς επιστρέφουμε στη φύση χρησιμοποιούμε την πιο ετσι παραδοσιακή μέθωτο δίννουμε
στα ζώαμα στα οποία θα βάλουμε στο στους αυρούς μέσα να εξεκινήσουν να να τρώνε
για να μπορέσουμε να αφερέσουμε και να μειώσουμε καύσιμηνήλη το ξεκινούμε πυροτσικά στην περιοχή του
τουπύργου τηληρίας δώσαμε να αποπέρσει τη δυνατότητα στις τοπικές αρχές να αποκτίσουν δόρααν θρηματιστές εργαζόμαστε
με τυναή παρακολουθούμε το σχεδιασμό της για να καθαρίζει τα καλόδια που πάντα πρέπει περιυρκαγές
εθντα να έχννηση από αυτά τακαλόπι αρα παρακολουθούμε βλέπουμε συνεχός των πρόγραμμα τισμόν τους θυμίζουμε
τις ενέργειες που κάνο είμαστε σε διαρκή επαφήμε το προεδρον της κγι αυτόν το πράγμα
και παραακολουθούμε τις ενέργειες τους καθαρίζουμε δρόμους τατην καύσιμελί που υπάρχει στην περιοχή για να
μπορούν τατα πυροσβεστικά χηματα ναπηγαίνουν του να είναι πιο ευκολι πρόσβαση αλλά για να φεύγου
νταξυρά χόρτα ενημερώνουμε τον κόσμο το πιο σημαντικό γιατί σχεδον όλες υ πυρκαγές προκαλον οι
θελημένα και πριασταματήσουν αυ οι κακές συνήθειες καθαρίσαμε ται ξεκινήσαμε να καθαρίζουμε πάρα πολλούς παράνομους
κυβαλλότοπους πέρα θιαγόσους εδώσαμε τη δυνατότητα ντην οικονομική δυνατότητα σε εκοινότητες σε δήμους που δεν
είχαν τα χρήματα γιατί είναι εδική τους αρμοδινητα παράνομης κυβαλλότοποι ύρταμε του είπμαμε τους έχουμε
να ανάμησει εκατομύριο στη διάθεσης σας ελάτε πάρτε χρήματα που τούτον το ταμίο να καθαρίσει
νε τους παράνομους κυβαλλότοπου σας προτερεότητα παραδασσος